stamping out abusive loopholes and eu
law that allow for the unfair treatment
of temporary workers from other eu
countries is the aim of the posting of
workers directive but at every stage the
legislation has divided opinion in the
house and amongst member states like
france who argue it will disadvantage
national workers for the author of the
report after over a year of negotiation
this imperative the vote is positive we
will vote for compromises it means that
we will start to work on this directive
at the beginning so two years of our job
will disappear and we never know what
will happen in the next term especially
if the next if in the next term there
will be
mostly
20 25 percent of nationalists probably
there will be much more difficult to get
the result we have just now
food safety rocketed up the agenda after
the horsemeat scandal meps want to
ensure that the 750 billion euro agri
food industry is better controlled by
ensuring that better standards of
practice within the food production
chain
part
of
organization
if you have to move for a good few
months to another member state and want
to take your own or company car any car
bus or truck driven will have to be
re-registered the eu wants to cut the
red tape to simplify the rules of car
registration to benefit businesses and
citizens
back in 2012 studies showed
re-registration was an issue that many
citizens saw as occurred their rights
but two years later are we closer to
reaching a deal problem is is to do
attacks that's the core of the issue
because in some countries they have very
high taxes on new motor vehicles
um and then if you bring a second car in
uh of course they they charge you a
calculated uh tax rate and the council
now i mean this was an issue on the
table at the beginning but they've now
decided they want to look at the issue
about tax again which is actually
nothing to do with the proposal
according to mr harper meps are expected
to postpone the vote in protest against
member states